so the inject a radio die into you to
sort of give you give them a snapshot of
what that is and then you go in the
machine the MRI machine and it scans but
he said this little spot right here he's
like tell me about uh psilocybin
mushrooms
I was like well
just got back from Burning Man
I'm kidding are there any studies on the
uh benefits of plant medicine and the
brain and neuroplasticity and new
neurons or
um or perhaps brain growth just in any
way like uh maybe we're activating
dormant DNA like drop it on us there you
go you I love it this is so such a cool
area of research like just one Ayahuasca
of course which is what you had
mentioned early yeah Johns Hopkins just
don't they put 17 million dollars in a
psilocybin research in the recent years
and one of the reasons they're doing
that they're putting and so we're
getting really good clinical studies
done again on this stuff
um and to your point there are they are
showing like read everything you can I
know you have but Paul stamets he's like
the mushroom Guru right oh yeah he was
that Burning Man too
so yeah without mushrooms without fungi
like this planet we're toast we need
that they're like the great equalizer
for our planet to keep our our
ecosystems alive things like that but it
also it's been shown to uh you know
psilocybin and mushroom derivatives like
lion's mane and whatnot have been shown
to increase nerve growth factors like
those proteins we were just talking
about change your microbiome in a
positive the good bacteria in you
regulate your immune responses just like
the lasers can do if your immune system
is overactive it'll calm it down if it's
under active it can help promote it so
yeah mushrooms are really good for that
but if you want to stabilize people that
are uh like bipolar for example for
example psilocybin is a way to do that
anxiety mushrooms can do that actually
technically all the classic psychedelics
like peyote and mescaline like Ayahuasca
like ibogaine psilocybin they all are
really good for stabilizing mood like
anxiety addiction for sure like if
you're if I was going to lose a kid to
like an opiate addiction like narcotics
or gotten like Fentanyl and all the
stuff that's going on right now I would
get them to an ibogaine Clinic they
don't have them in the United States
anymore but they have them in Canada
I have again it's it's it's like the
grandfather it's a it's a African
derivative that's the ultimate reset
button it takes all of your egos
okay
yeah it's a big one that's a big one and
I'm gonna tell you right now Danica I
tried it because I'm not one to tell
people to go do something if I haven't
read it myself sure I I sat for a day
with iboga and it was the hardest 24
hours of my life it literally Rings up
everything about your psyche your ego
that kind of stuff but you come out like
literally studies show and and both you
know anecdotally as well too people come
out of these iboga clinics completely
free of opiate addiction and things like
that but in a smaller scale mushrooms
like psilocybin can do it
Ayahuasca is like the master uh is the
mother ceremony it is the one that you
know it's when you think think of the
the best analogy I give it's like a
near-death experience you hear about
these stories of people you know you
know they've died for some reason
clinically and they're getting drawn to
the light and they're being with God and
things like that that energy that love
that is God's energy kind of thing is
you know that Universal love and you I
know we've both had experiences where
it's like that's you if you're in that
place it's the most euphoric like words
can't do it justice no it's an it's an
awareness it's not even like you can't
the words are not don't there's too much
essentially there's just too much
information it's not you can't break it
down into a sentence you can't break it
down into a conversation it holds way
more information than that because it in
fact it you can feel it too it's very
it's hard to describe the way something
feels just like you can't like
articulate or Define love necessarily
similar like you can't it's too much
information yeah it's it's the pureness
that's Indescribable and my man ego
would never be able to do it justice so
what what they've done and where I'm
getting to with this is if you one of
the things that Johns Hopkins is working
is they're giving cancer patients so
high dose and that I'm careful set and
setting right that's right right right
and these are scheduled you know when
you look at their you know the
substances are legal mostly in the
United States some some places are
starting to decriminalize them
thankfully but as a brain person they
are one of the most important things
that we're going to get to with
neuropsych stuff like depression like
anxiety because ssris and stuff I'm
sorry that's not doing anything exercise
will blow ssris let alone diet we'll
blow ssris I mean I feel like you hear
uh you know the Peterson Family Michaela
and Jordan talk a lot about that kind of
stuff Michaela's been very forthcoming
with all of that and how diet cured it
all not ssris and the the backlash of
that it was so detrimental yeah and and
so the fear of dying like because with
cancer if it comes back that's you know
that's not a good sign so what they do
is they give people with life
life-threatening illnesses when they
give them a psilocybin like a hero's
dose as they talk about where you you
have that god-like experience if that's
what's waiting for us on the other side
guess what people lose their fear of
dying when I had my God like Ayahuasca
weekend it was my first time sitting
with Ayahuasca it was the worst trip I
could ever imagine but I'm of the belief
there's no such thing as a bad trip so
to speak because once I finally let go
of my ego and my default mode Network
and I truly in my deepest sense at the
time when I was on that trip I said I ha
I just want to die right now but I meant
it in like the the root of my core and
every cell every DNA of my body I felt
that feeling and as soon as I truly felt
that I went into this space and I got
projected into the space of dark energy
and dark matter and I was with God's
energy and love and it was just the most
and it was literally like a light switch
turned off when I truly let myself die
yeah not just like oh I'm gonna let go
but when you just just embody letting go
there's a big difference between saying
letting go and feeling letting go to
truly embody an emotion is the magic of
the universe Bingo and that's why
leading with your heart like one of the
ceremonies I sat with the shaman came
over and I was stuck my energy was stuck
everyone's in ceremony it was like 14 of
us on our mats and I was stuck and he
was working with my energy and moving
around he leaned Into Me Goes Trevor you
got an amazing brain he's your
intelligence that he goes quit
using it use your heart
the shaman put his hand on my heart and
as soon as I did that everything just
opened up and didn't you just post
something today on social media about
using leading with your heart yeah all
the thoughts and stuff and so yeah it's
it's so to get to those places sometimes
those plant-based medicines allow us to
see things that we could never do when
we're stuck in our default mode Network
in those salience networks and our
Central Network system because we start
to perseverate and we sometimes when
that sled is going down the hill and
it's stuck in that Groove from that
Fresh coat of powder so that that sled
can go down a different route down that
hill and your life begins you know in a
whole different trajectory and that's
what the plant-based medicines do in
ways that to your point making new
Pathways and these Pathways they're
showing now in long-term studies like
the Johns Hopkins major depression study
not just a month later but they just did
a year follow-up that showed they were
still good A year later with depression
so it's a long-term neuroplasticity new
connections that kind of stuff and yes
the classic psychedelics can do all that
to dovetail off the Psychedelic side of
things if you look at you know you hear
these terms like we only use x percent
of our brain in our current form as it
is and our constructs our man-made
limitations or you know self-limitations
if you will
um we only get to appreciate certain
elements but if you think of it as
universal intelligence like there's an
energy out there and again this gets
into those definition things is it God
you know everyone's definition of God is
you know different that kind of thing
that energy that that is out there and
they're starting to study it more like
the CERN super collider you know the
news and God Particle all that stuff but
as we look into that that's one of the
things that plant-based medicine does it
allows us to peer over our own veil of
ego in our own limitations and look into
that bigger picture and so there's some
thought that what you know we're just
we're getting that Universal waveform
that we're all into interconnected and
that our Consciousness just intersects
the those waves because you know
everything the quantum models everything
that's exactly what it is yeah
everything's a wave right and it's when
our con when we look at a table and
touch it's our Consciousness that
intersects those waves and turns it into
you know how we describe it and how
because non-locality has been proven the
table's not really here until observed
that's it that's proven now and that's
one of the beautiful things about
mescaline and peyote is that it allowed
me I I felt like I literally was one
with the world the mount I was actually
being buried alive out in the desert and
the beauty of it I had no fear I had no
it was like this is the coolest thing I
was connected to the Mount like all
these inanimate objects like mountains
and everything was becoming one and
that's what you know that's part of
those Vision quests those trips is just
to appreciate that we're all connected
our vibration you know you talked about
quantum entanglement we will go two
different directions and yet still have
the exact same properties you know going
either way and that kind of thing but
then you look at
um how Consciousness when we look at it
for more of a reductionist model so I'm
we've been talking a lot about expanding
outside you know in that direction but
as we start to look inside of the human
body and how we're made up of fractals
our universe is fractals our the
worldliness trees ferns I when I
messaged you the other day I said you
know my spirit animal is what Romanesco
broccoli it's that fractal pattern and
one of those beautiful vegetable in the
world right isn't it and so one thing I
know when I'm sitting in in ceremony is
that when I start seeing those fractal
patterns a lot of people are cool with
that it's like this cool visual
Kaleidoscope right that's actually
almost like a Gateway that tells me oh
I'm about to have a big lesson coming my
way and once you get through those
fractal patterns then you open up to the
other side and she gives you know these
medicines give different teachings each
time like I sat with Ayahuasca now about
14 times I've had a different experience
completely every time because it's such
a great saying and doesn't give you what
you want it gives you what you need
Bingo and you just literally took the
words right out of my own so mother
nature is a pattern making machine look
at look at your cardiovascular system
tree roots that's right that's your
blood vessels in your heart look at that
fractal pattern the studies show if you
look at fractal patterns in that range
you'll have a 60 reduction in stress oh
my God you're reorganizing your brain
yeah so we're fractal beings we're using
it now even like look at Ben Weiss's uh
Ted Talk on fractals he's kind of like
one of Mabel brought's disciples they're
using those mandelbrot sets in learning
disability in cognitive behavioral stuff
things like that just based on Staring
at a fractal pattern Activation so then
you look at it inside your body your
lung feels like the bronchial tree your
capillary your blood vessel then your
brain all those folds on top of each
other are fractal patterns your neurons
all the dendrites that connect to each
other it's all fractal patterns and it
looks exactly well like and I did
download one more and I did this small
because if you look yeah oh yeah neuro
neurons one's a neuron one's the
universe yeah exactly of course you
can't tell the difference because
they're a fractal because no matter how
much you zoom in or how much you zoom
out it's the same pattern exactly so now
we go keep going into the neuron now
we're back to the microtubule that we
started with and the quantum
Consciousness model of Penrose and
hamura is to say that with to have a
super computer that like if you do
Quantum Computing it's non-binary right
it's not one and zero it's somewhere in
between and it can be in any
configuration at any time so to be able
to have this type of activity you have
to have fractal patterns that the
electrons are bouncing around it and
that's what they are saying is the
theory of quantum Consciousness is the
fractal pattern in that microtubule so
in a in a you know when you look at it
from a reductionist standpoint it's not
because it's actually opening up into
that realm of those fractal patterns in
our brains that are tapping into the
universal connectiveness of fractal
patterns that are never ending the most
recent studies that are being done
there's like a serpinski triangle some
of the top Quantum researchers are
trying to create a model that that they
could use as the model for Quantum you
know quantum mechanics guess what
they're doing to activate this this
triangle it's the fractal model that
they're using is that they put a photon
of light into the tip of it and guess
what happens
it exponentially communicates with the
entire fractal pattern so this gets into
why light therapies we're we're light
driven beings if without the sun we're
not here without light energy without
that kind of wavelength and we're not
here we don't exist plants don't exist
we're toast if you like this clip and
you want to hear the whole episode click
at the bottom of your screen